So, Leute, auf geht's.
Circa
zwei Stunden, aber Zeit
bis 13 Uhr, kurz nach 13 Uhr.
Ich muss übrigens noch die Kategorie umstellen,
ich weiß.
Was? Ich bin ab heute Mittag da, wenn du mal...
Klar, klar.
Klar.
Ich bin jetzt erst mal bis 13 Uhr on.
Dann gehe ich was futtern
und grinde ich wahrscheinlich
eine Runde Passive Exile oder mal gucken.
Ich muss aber noch die Kategorie
umstellen.
Können schon mal gucken, welchen Server
wir drauf gehen.
Also die Frage ist, geben wir uns den
den 64-Mann-Wahnsinn?
Wie gesagt, ich muss erst mal
die Kategorie umstellen.
Ja, da, wunderbar.
Ich muss erst mal
die Kategorie umstellen.
Streamkategorie ändern.
Ja, danke.
Mein Streaming-Rechner startet noch.
Ich kann gerade noch nichts umstellen.
So, erst mal...
Warum habe ich da immer noch Skype installiert?
Alter, Skype, lull.
Oh, mega, lull.
So.
Battlefield 5.
Nein, nein, nein, Battlefield 3.
Battlefield 5, ich glaube, es geht los.
Wer spielt schon?
Ah, wer spielt schon
freiwillig noch Battlefield 5?
So, Kategorie ist umgestellt.
Wunderbar.
Also schauen wir mal. Komm, wir gehen erst mal hier drauf.
Ich habe ja schon ein paar Tage nicht mehr gespielt.
Mal gucken, ob ich wieder eingerostet bin
oder ob es noch geht.
Ah, Battlefield verlernt man nicht.
Easy.
Musik muss ich kurz mal ausmachen.
Und hoffen, dass der sich die Lautstärke gemerkt hat.
Mein T muss ich auf die andere Seite stellen,
weil sonst schmeiße ich ihn mit der Maus um.
Okay, es geht ja gut los.
Metro.
Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub, Void Danny.
Zehn Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Okay, wir sind
Defense
und kriegen auf den Sack.
Moment, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Was ist das hier?
Ah, okay, geht halbwegs.
Wir sind Defense und kriegen auf den Sack.
Perfekt.
Die legen, die legen.
Ich bilde mir A, ich habe A gehört. Kann das sein?
Lululul.
Okay, wir stellen uns jetzt hier lang.
Gucken, ob wir da was von der Seite gebasht haben.
Ich kann es nicht kriegen, Alter.
Hier ist nix.
Ich sehe nix.
Wow, wow, what, what, what, fuck.
Hier ist nix.
Gegner, please.
Oh, ich habe das falsche, ich habe das falsche Attachment.
Ich brauche Cover.
Ich brauche Cover, sonst, sonst wird das nix.
Sonst kann ich da nix machen.
Alter, Battlefield, please.
Okay, die kommen jetzt gleich hier aus der Mitte, gestelzt.
Okay.
Okay, auf geht's.
Wo sind sie denn?
Oh, ja, natürlich in der Ecke sitzt er irgendwo da.
Rein ins Ge...
Oh, oh, ich werde gerätzt.
Das hätt ich nicht gedacht, dass ich gerätzt werde.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Sachen gibt's.
Lul.
Ich hätte nicht vorrushen sollen.
Ich hätte einfach, ich hätte es einfach abcampen müssen.
Einfach hardcore abcampen, das Ganze.
So, so wie der es hier macht.
Der macht es gut.
Der campt das eigentlich erstmal hart ab.
Exzellent.
Oh, oh, oh, hier ist es ganz schön voll.
Hauen wir mal eine Granate drüber.
Gucken wir mal oben rum.
Oh, der runter.
Kann man hier durchgucken?
Lul.
Headglitch.
Headglitch is real, Alter.
Oh.
Hör auf, mich zu snipen.
Der hat mich wirklich, der hat mich versucht zu snipen.
Kann man, man kann sich hier irgendwo, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
man kann sich irgendwo unter, unter die U-Bahn legen.
Komm.
Komm her.
Lul.
Wie man da schön in die Ecke campt, Alter.
Ist ja geil.
Wurde der gerätzt?
Da ist er, da ist er.
Da ist er.
Komm her.
Der wird jetzt gerätzt, dann wird er gleich wieder gekillt.
Das ist ja geil, die kannst du ja abcampen auf Doom.
Ich habe keine Granate.
Okay, die haben nicht gerätzt, das heißt, der ist jetzt weg.
Hallo, springen.
Bringen.
Bringen, Sohn.
Go, go.
Camper eats for life.
Hey, wir sind Defender.
Das ist der einzige Spielmodus, wo es echt erlaubt ist, Hardcore zu campen.
Okay, okay, okay.
Moment, Flank Reno.
Excellent.
Excellent Flank Action.
Ey, ey, lass mir was übrig, Alter.
Wo sind denn die?
Wo, wo, wo sind die genau?
Kann das Stoppschild sich mal verpissen?
Haha.
Wow, da, da, da, da aimt er schon mit seinem komischen,
mit seinem komischen Flashlight.
Mit seinem komischen Flashlight.
Äh, taktisches Warten.
So sieht es aus.
Oh, oh.
What?
Das war jetzt hier aber Big, Big, Biggest, Biggest Brain.
Biggest Brain, äh, äh, Headshot ever.
Moment, ist, lebt der noch?
Oh, was ist da hinten los?
Fuck, was ist da hinter uns los?
Monka.
Monka ist.
Nein.
Da, da stellst du rum.
Ah, aber wir haben die voll, die krassen Retzer bei uns am Start.
Was ist da los?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, in your ass.
In ass geballert.
In ass gesprayt.
Okay.
This arm, this arm, this arm, this arm, this arm, this arm, this arm, this arm, this arm.
Excellent.
Big, Biggest Brain Moves.
Biggest Brain Moves.
Five Head, Six Head, Seven Head, Eight Head.
Hyper Head.
Was ist denn hier los gerade?
Das ist doch nicht mehr normal.
Ich traue mich nicht, dich zu retzen, Alter.
Hier rennen so viele Leute.
Ist das über uns?
Excellent.
Okay, okay, die holen wir jetzt.
Okay, okay.
Warum hat der Dude das überlebt?
Der lebt noch, der lebt noch, der lebt noch.
Oh, jetzt werden sie aber gesprayt, ey.
Andere Seite, da ist auch noch einer.
Kommst du her?
Kollege, du musst hier lang.
Ich weiß, dass du hier lang bist.
Da unten war noch einer.
Ich sehe den nicht, wegen dem Schild.
Schild, Schild, geh weg.
Monka, Schild.
Okay, ihr macht das schon, Leute.
Ihr macht das, ihr macht das, ihr macht das.
Wie wir Erster sind, 16-1.
Easy Clap.
Easiest Clap.
Alter, der lebt noch.
Ihr könnt doch nicht alle den D-4 rausholen jetzt.
Lebt der noch?
Oh, what?
Max, I'm carrying, Hardcore Carry.
Das ist angesagt.
Die pushen aber auch richtig hart.
Oh, oh, oh, ich muss weg.
Okay.
Okay, erstmal eins zurück.
Erstmal, erstmal, erstmal Winkel ein bisschen ändern hier.
Da ist er doch.
Kollege, ich sehe dich, ich sehe dich.
Leute, erinnert mich, wenn ich sterbe.
Ich muss Quad Cover machen.
Ohne Squad Cover geht da nichts.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt hier einfach durch und machen die
Flank Action of Doom.
Haha.
Okay, okay, wir stellen es uns jetzt von hinten ran.
Fuck.
Geile Flank Action Ausführung, mangelhaft.
Squad Cover, Squad Cover.
Chat, Big Brain Chat, Big Brain Chat.
Äh, Squad Cover.
Ah, habe ich doch schon.
Habe ich doch schon.
Okay, hat sich erledigt.
Corona Iran, alles klar.
Corona Iran.
Corona Iran, ey.
MonkaS, was ist hier los?
Ich dachte, der Typ lebt unter mir.
Ich habe da noch drauf geschossen.
Ach nee, das sind zwei.
Das eine ist eine Leiche und das andere ist der Typ, der hinter seiner Munibox liegt.
Aha, verstehe.
Oh, Corona Iran geht da richtig ab.
Lull.
Aber ich hoffe, wir haben, guck mal, noch 13 Tickets.
Was soll ich denn großartig machen?
Wobei, also die pushen ja links wirklich ganz gut gerade.
Aber Corona Iran hat es.
Corona Iran macht es.
Der Name, ja.
Wow.
Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei.
Ja.
Äh.
Ich denke, als da hängt ein Gegner.
Okay, jetzt wurde er gekillt.
Nein.
Ab aim, ab aim, ab aim.
Please, komm um die Ecke.
Komm um die Ecke.
Ich kann nicht aufstehen.
Ich weiß genau, der kommt in dem Moment um die Ecke, wo ich aufstehe.
Was?
Die haben einen fucking Charge.
Oh.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Die haben einen Charge gesetzt.
Alter, das ist das letzte Ticket, Mann.
Das letzte fucking scheiß Ticket.
Ah, nee, okay.
Die lassen sich aber gut sprengen, die Jungs hier.
Ha.
Easy.
Erstmal Stream snipen.
Wenn hier gestream sniped wird, gibt es Instant Bun.
Bam, bam, bam.
Corona Iran, Mann.
Der ging ab.
Dazu kann man nur sagen.
Äh.
Warum?
Ah, oh, meine Emotes sind ein bisschen groß gerade.
Corona Iran sollten eine Runde Hände waschen nach der Runde.
Das bist du?
Bist du Corona Iran?
Bester Name, ey.
Excellent.
So muss das sein.
Mal gucken, was jetzt für eine Map kommt.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und kriegen nochmal eine Runde Metro Attacker.
Ach, hier, guck mal, sind ja einige aus dem Stream dabei.
Excellent.
So.
Mal gucken, was jetzt kommt.
Ich hoffe, wir haben noch eine Runde Metro Attacker.
Come on.
Ah, yes.
Metro Attacker.
An der ersten Base entscheidet sich es immer meistens schon, wie gut man durchkommt.
Wenn man easy as fuck durch die erste Base kommt, ist meistens die restliche Runde auch easy mode.
Volle Pulle.
Kopf aus und volle Pulle drauf.
War das, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, war es Bad Company 2 oder war es Battlefield 3, wo man ein bisschen schneller war, weil man gesprungen ist?
Easy, easy.
Ich aim ab oben.
Alter, kannst du nicht mal hier hochhüpfen?
Nope.
Ja, wenn ihr diffusen wollt, kriegt ihr auf den Sack.
By the way.
Ich halte mal die Ecke hier.
Okay, das wird easy.
Das wird easy.
Ich sag's euch, easy as fuck.
Ich hab Schiss vor dem Dude rechts.
Alter, kannst du mal deinen Kopf rausschrecken?
Lol.
Wie er fliegt.
Wie er geflogen ist, habt ihr das gesehen?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, ob ich dich retzen kann.
Ach, boah.
Daran merkt man, wenn das Team was taugt.
Wenn sich vier Leute mit Defi auf den einzelnen Toten stürzen, dann weißt du alles gut.
Dann weißt du, Team taugt.
Okay.
Erstmal den ordentlichen Weg gehen.
Also der ordentliche Weg ist eigentlich da.
Nein, das ist nicht der ordentliche Weg, by the way.
Das ist der Sacker-Weg.
Fällt mir gerade...
Oh.
Okay, vielleicht gehe ich doch mit.
Oder ich weiß nicht.
Meine Leute verrecken da.
Das hier ist der richtige Weg.
Das da und dann links oder das am besten hier in der Mitte am Rand und dann...
Jetzt kommt's drauf an.
An der Base.
Oh.
Aber erstmal 20 Leute haben sich auf mich geschürzt zum Retzen.
Nee, nee, nee, Kollege.
So nicht.
Fuck, da links steht noch einer.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ah, wir sind richtig gut durch.
Wir sind richtig gut durch.
Was ist das?
War das ein Spawn?
Sah ein Spawn-Beacon so aus?
Erstmal hier hoch.
Hoch.
Hallo.
Game, please.
Ich stecke in der Decke.
Okay, wir müssen hier durch.
Okay, wir müssen hier hoch.
Wir müssen hier hoch.
Oh, oh.
Ah, wie viele Gegner.
Monka.
Okay.
Die Gegner kriegen auf den Sack.
Die Gegner kriegen richtig auf den Sack.
Hahaha.
Lull.
Alter, was ein Pro.
Ja, ich habe auf die Pistole geswitcht.
Huge Pro Plays.
Oh, es ruckelt.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Pro Plays sind.
Oh, hier ist immer hart.
Hier ist immer echt so eine Sache für sich.
Die Treppe.
Ist quasi die Corona-Treppe.
Nur die Harten kommen durch.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ja, Medipack.
Erstmal das Zeug hier wegziehen.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich das Zeug wegmachen.
Wo sitzen sie denn?
Da hinten ist nichts.
Ich sehe nichts.
Da.
Ja, da war er.
Okay, ich hole dich.
Ich hole dich, Kollege.
Ah.
Ich weiß immer nicht, ob die Laser von unseren Leuten...
Jetzt gehen wir durch.
Oh.
Aber jetzt stürmen unsere Leute.
Bam, bam, bam.
Jetzt kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Jawohl.
Nee, fuck die.
Oh, oh, oh.
Manchmal ist es besser.
Man rätst einfach nur sinnlos rum.
Einfach der Rätstrain.
Solange der Rätstrain am Start ist, kannst du kaum verlieren.
Siehste?
Wir haben jetzt nur gewonnen, weil ich gerätst habe.
So sieht es aus.
Oh, oh, oh.
Deswegen haben wir Squadcover dabei.
Squadcover-Beste.
Guck um die Ecke.
Guck um die Ecke, Kollege.
Ich will das...
Jeder guckt mich um die Ecke.
Hat keinen Bock.
Lege, Helme.
Lege, Helme ist am Start.
Exzellent.
Ich sehe überhaupt keine Gegner, so schnell sind die down.
Oh, oh, oh.
What the...
Okay, aber die wollen es schon.
Die wollen es teilweise echt wissen, ne?
Lege, Helme.
Also, eins muss man sagen.
Mein Team ist echt heiß, ja?
Die sind echt scharf drauf.
Oh.
Also, wenn wir Glück haben, sind wir schnell genug drin, dass wir hier bleiben können.
Oder auch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oh, oh, oh.
Weggeschneibt, die Sau.
Jetzt aber.
Oh, ich darf nicht springen, wir sind nicht in Call of Duty, Alter.
Äh, hallo?
Gegner?
Wo ist der Gegner hin?
Oh, ich krieg...
Laser in your face.
Laser voll ins Gesicht, Alter.
Retzen.
Das Allerwichtigste in dem Game.
Äh, nein.
Ihr könnt nicht...
mich hier gar nicht treffen, Leute. Ausgeschlossen,
ausgeschlossen. Geht nicht.
Ist nicht bangable,
die Wand. Haha, Kopf.
Nochmal Kopf.
Na, okay, Halbkopf.
Geht so was?
Halber Headshot.
50% Headshot.
Okay, jetzt machen wir den
Big Brain Flank. Der klappt wahrscheinlich nicht,
aber wir können es probieren.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Aber du hast nur einen Nade-Kollege.
Du kommst bestimmt da oben raus jetzt.
Oh!
Ich wusste, dass der da oben rauskommt.
Ich hab ein bisschen zu früh weggeguckt.
M1416
OP, change my mind. Ja, ganz einfach.
M16. Ebenfalls
OP. Ja, dann ist alles...
Dann ist ja alles OP.
Erstmal eine Nade draufschmeißen.
Ich seh da nämlich nichts mehr.
Alter, was ist mit dem Haus los?
Ja, die Waffen sind auch gut.
Der Ingame-Jet. Ich hab jetzt...
Was hab ich verpasst im Ingame-Jet?
Ich hab...
Leider kann man nicht mal in den Ingame-Jet gucken.
Leider kann man nicht mal in den
Ingame-Jet gucken.
Baby-Rage. Geflame. Ach so, okay.
Moment, Moment.
Während das läuft, Moment. Das Geflame muss ich mir schnell angucken.
Ah, kurz.
Moment.
Äh, ähm...
What? Das Geflame
muss ich mir schnell anschauen. Was wurde da geflamed?
Oh.
Exquisite Qualität.
Sad language. Was?
Null.
Nice, nice Flames.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen...
Was? Nochmal Metro?
Wir hatten doch gerade das Metro.
Ist das ein Metro-Only-Server?
Das sollte eigentlich nicht ein Metro-Only-Server sein.
Äh...
Moment, wo konnte man sich nochmal die Rotation angucken?
Wir haben doch schon zweimal Metro gespielt.
Map Rotation Metro. Hä?
Wir haben schon zwei Runden Metro gespielt.
Wie kann das sein?
Dass wir nochmal Metro spielen?
Wir haben Defense Metro gespielt.
Attack Metro und jetzt nochmal Defense Metro.
Ich bin übrigens zu spät gespawnt.
Das war nicht gut.
Nein.
Nein. Nein.
Ihr könnt mich nicht treffen. Ist unmöglich.
Excellent.
Lululululul.
Unmöglich. Zu hinten.
Ich hab den T-Bag gemacht.
Den M-Com T-Bag.
Da ist man...
Da ist man unverwundbar mit.
Wenn man den M-Com T-Bag macht.
M-Com T-Bag OP.
Okay.
Ich muss hier unten mal kurz campen und warten, was kommt.
Ich muss hier mal in der Ecke stehen bleiben.
Weil ich weiß, dass hier gleich Gegner kommen.
Und wir haben kaum Leute vorne.
Wir haben kaum Leute vorne.
Übrigens, links läuft einer rum.
Ich hab den gemarkt, aber...
Hinterm Baum ist noch einer, hä?
Ich kann hier nicht weg.
Ich kann hier echt nicht weg.
Die drücken so hart rein.
Die drücken so...
Alter!
Die drücken so hart rein, die Gegner.
Jetzt wollen sie es echt wissen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ihr hittet mich nicht mehr.
Ihr hittet mich nicht.
Ich weiß, dass ihr mich nicht hittet.
Ihr könnt mich nicht hitten.
Oh.
Okay.
Also, eins muss ich nur sagen.
Der Red Strain ist on point.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir irgendwie B defenden.
Was ziemlich schwierig ist, ehrlich gesagt, wenn A weg ist.
Wir dürfen auf jeden Fall nicht vergessen, die Seite zu halten.
Streck den Kopf raus.
Ja, ist klar, das hat er nicht getroffen.
Ist logisch.
Battlefield 0.
Hallo.
Okay, gehen wir mal rüber.
Ich glaub, die push...
Links ist nix.
Die pushen.
Fuck.
Wohoho.
Äh, morgen kann man irgendwo seine PC-Specs sehen.
Äh, ähm...
Äh, äh, äh...
Äh, äh, äh, äh, ich bin mit...
Hallo, ich kann hier aufstehen?
MonkaS?
What?
Ah!
Konsol-Kommade.
Oh, da oben ist einer.
Also meine PC-Specs, ich kann sie dir sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man die irgendwo sieht.
Ähm, nach 1700K, 1800Ti, 16G RAM.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lässt du mich in Ruhe?
Excellent.
Wo seid ihr?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
So, ja.
Next.
Oh, hier ist so viel los.
Der hat Push drüber, ich muss den holen.
Leute, drückt mal ein bisschen vor.
BF3-Retzen ist huge.
Okay, mal bei Corona Iran rein spawnen.
Der Name ist zu bester, ey.
Oh, what?
Weggeschneibert.
Okay, jetzt haben sie die erste Base.
Die Runde macht doch schon mal mehr Bock.
Äh, Mark Blah sagt, hab letztens mal wieder MW2 gespielt über das neue alte IW-Net.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es ein neues alte IW-Net überhaupt gibt.
Wo bekommt man denn das neue alte IW-Net?
Ja, ist ja gut hier, genug gesniped, Alter.
Ja, hör auf zu snipen, Mann.
Ja, alles klar.
Erstmal bam, bam, bam, bam, zusammen umfallen.
Das war so ein typischer Battlefield 3 Hit Detection Ding.
Da machst du nix.
Manchmal hab ich das Gefühl, das macht das Game absichtlich, um dich aus der Gegner-Base rauszukriegen.
Aber wenn es zu offensichtlich ist, dann sagt das Game, okay, wenigstens kriegen beide den Kill, dass es nicht zu offensichtlich ist.
IW-4X.
Okay.
Ist das das neue?
Also, spielt...
Spielen das viele?
Oh.
Ja, sag mal.
Kann ich mal was killen jetzt?
Danke.
Den nächsten, ich glaub, den kann ich nicht holen.
Ah, shit.
Ich hab's probiert, ich hab's probiert.
Aber komm, ihr kriegt mich, Leute.
Ja, excellent.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, wie sieht's aus?
Mitte ist gut, wir müssen links halten.
Oh.
Gegnerus.
Was ist jetzt los hier?
Jetzt wird man jetzt einmal wirklich über Hardcore gebasht, ey.
Bam, bam, bam.
Krieg ich noch einen Ratz?
Oder bin ich nicht retzbar?
Ich glaub, ich bin nicht retzbar.
Man findet fünf bis zehn volle...
Das ist doch gar nicht schlecht.
Ich mein, das ist MW-2.
MW-2 ist, äh, ist wie alt?
Zehn Jahre oder so?
Moment, wo bin ich?
Wow.
Wie viele Gegner sind das denn?
Monka.
Monka-X.
Alter, was ist hier los gerade?
Pff.
Elf Jahre fast, ja.
Heftig.
Was ist das jetzt denn in der Ecke, äh?
Oh, ist das jetzt die Autoshotgun hier?
Okay, jetzt haben die jetzt entweder...
Haben die Gegner jetzt die Ultra-Pros ausgepackt?
Aber man weiß nicht so genau.
Was war eigentlich hier rüber?
M-2000...
Äh, F-2000.
Ja, ex...
Excellent.
F-2 Excellent.
Was?
Okay, also langsam blicke ich bei den Gegnern immer durch.
Pff.
Haben die jetzt erstmal...
Activated.
Boah, hier geht's aber ab, ey.
MP5-Hipfire, ja.
Auch, auch.
Excellent.
Okay, wir haben hier echt ne Scheiß-Pose.
Mega Scheiß-Posi.
Was ist hier los?
Pff, pfiu, pfiu.
Okay, wir können uns jetzt ans M-Com campen
und gucken, dass wir vielleicht irgendwas erwischen.
Äh, Map, Map, Map.
Äh, äh, boah, boah.
Okay, ähm, Map.
Was haben wir zur Auswahl?
Bazaar?
Nee, äh, J.
Slash.
Terran Highway.
Terran Highway ist so underrated.
Ein richtig guter Map.
Terran Highway ist pogger, poggers.
Okay.
Die Gegner, die sind mir grad ein bisschen zu aggressiv.
Die Gegner sind mir zu aggressiv.
Thanos 6598, alles klar.
Ich kann da nicht hin.
Ich kann da nicht hin, das ist ausgeschlossen.
Da aimen mich vier Gegner ab.
Alter, guckt es euch an.
Da aimen mich fünf Gegner ab.
Was willst du denn da machen, ey?
Ich könnte mal was retzen, aber wo liegen die überhaupt?
Okay, vielleicht haben wir es jetzt mal kurz,
kurzzeitig die Gegner ge-ge-ge-gebashed.
Oh ne, oh fuck, die sind auf der anderen Seite.
Oder sie, die sind oben drüber.
Die sind oben drüber.
Die müssen wir oben bashen.
Alles weg?
Ey, okay, sie kommen rechts, sie kommen rechts, sie kommen rechts.
Was ist mit den Gegnern grad los?
Du verdammt.
What the fuck?
Kommst du nicht her, gib es down.
Wow, wow.
Okay, aber die Runde geht wenigstens mal in beide Richtungen was.
Das ist tatsächlich, äh, bisschen anstrengend.
Nein, nein, nein, lasst mich, lasst mich doch in Ruhe.
Aber wenigstens, so, genau so, endlich mal eine Runde wie Battlefield 3.
Von hinten mit der Spaß.
Endlich mal was wie Battlefield 3 gespielt wird.
Volle Pulle Redstrain und in your face die ganze Zeit gepusht.
Da ist übrigens was los.
Bald kommt Max.
Ja, ich bin demnächst, Dings, hier bei, bei, AK, wie heißt der?
AKA, Dings, da, äh, in der Battlefield Moments Montage.
Battlefield Moments Montage.
Spaß 12 Killing Streak.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Oh, jetzt überrennen sie uns aber.
Ne, bei dem kann ich nicht rein spawnen.
Ist der gespawn im M-Com?
Ne, ne?
Okay.
Let's go.
Lull.
Erst mal, erst mal schön.
Komm.
YOLO.
Was?
Moment.
Warum hat das keinen gekillt?
Haben wir es, haben wir es entschärft?
Ne, ne?
Ah, ne, es ist down, es ist down.
Okay.
Excellent.
Da fallen mir die Gegner nicht um.
Na, also ich mag Hardcore gar nicht.
Das Problem an Hardcore in Battlefield 3 und beziehungsweise auch in Battlefield 4 war,
dass da halt alle nur schneipsern.
Und irgendwo rumsitzen.
Die sind alle nur am Snipen.
Braucht man noch, äh...
Ja, ja, man braucht noch die Browserspielsuche.
Ja, ja.
Fall back.
Blyat.
Wir müssen übrigens gucken, dass da von hinten nichts kommt.
Btw.
By the way, die machen das richtig.
Wo sind sie?
Wo seid ihr?
Was?
Wie?
Sind die nicht gestorben?
Nein.
Oh shit.
Ist hier viel los.
Oh ne, das ist ja Battlefield.
Da muss man den Scheiß erst kaputt machen, dass man retzen kann.
Da muss man ja immer die Boxen erst kaputt schießen.
Man muss ja die Boxen kaputt schießen, dass man retzen darf.
Das war ja Battlefield 3-Logik.
Der Defi killt Leute, äh...
Der Defi belebt komplett zerfetzte Leute wieder.
Aber...
Ähm...
ETF.
Aber durch eine Kiste durch geht das nicht.
Die legen gerade.
Oh, ne.
Der hat voll den RPG gefressen bei der Legehände.
Sag mal, was ist hier gerade los?
Ich...
Ich sterbe, bin wiederbelebt, sterbe.
Die Battlefield Experience ist am Start hier.
Aber die drücken richtig gut, die Gegner.
Deswegen ist es mal eine ordentliche Runde.
Ah, fuck.
Ich wollte ihm seine Waffe aufheben.
Äh, was zum...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie der das gelegt hat gerade.
Oh, hinter uns.
Scheiße.
Der muss da weg.
Im Häuschen.
Im Dings Häuschen.
Im Funk Häuschen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Ding genau heißt.
Was weiß ich?
Battlefield Callouts noch.
Ey, das ist 10 Jahre her, das Game.
Genau, mach den platt, Alter.
Oder lass mich spawnen, Buddy.
Ist auch okay.
Excellent.
Ihr habt mal einen guten, guten Blick.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ah.
Lasst euch mal...
Was?
Oh, links ist einer durch.
Links ist einer durch.
Ich seh den.
Ich hab...
Okay.
Shit.
Ey.
Das ist...
Die sind nicht schlecht.
Die sind echt nicht schlecht.
Da...
Da geht was.
Rush B reicht als Callout.
Ja.
Könnte man joinen.
Theoretisch.
Theoretisch kannst du joinen.
Ja.
Falls noch Platz ist.
Oh.
Was will der?
Will der den Löwe in den Ass snipen?
Man kann da anscheinend nicht spawnen.
Hier haben wir die letzten schon mal gehalten.
Also in einem der letzten Games.
Nicht vorne.
Wir machen jetzt hier die...
Die...
Die Flank.
Der Typ mit dem Sniper ist bloß mad.
Das Gefühl hab ich auch.
Woah.
Fuck.
Ich wollte gerade umdrehen.
Ich wusste nicht, dass da schon das ganze Gegnerteam steht.
Fuck.
Pushen.
Pushen Reno.
Die sind aber gut drauf hier.
Aber das letzte Mal haben wir die hier auch gehalten.
Okay.
Äh.
Wo ist der Typ?
Die...
Die pushen hier gerade durch.
Oh.
Ey.
Der macht's übrigens richtig da unten links auf der Map.
Ne?
Genau so.
Das...
Da hab ich ja vorhin auch gestanden.
Genau da musste hin.
Oh.
Wo sind wir denn hier jetzt?
Bei...
Bei Corona im Haus.
Exce...
Fuck.
Nein.
Corona.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich guck genau in die falsche Richtung.
The Burger Man.
Oh.
Ich hab Hunger.
Stunde.
Stunde gibt's Essen.
Aber kein...
Aber keine Burgers.
Äh.
Band...
Bandnudeln und Lachs gibt's in der Stunde.
Nein.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Also die sind geil auf uns.
Die Gegner.
Die sind auf...
Die sind definitiv scharf drauf.
Die Gegner sind definitiv richtig scharf auf uns.
Die sind extrem scharf auf uns.
Aaah!
Durch die Wand schießen da.
Was ist das?
Guck mal der Chat wie sie sich wieder beleidigen müssen.
Lass mich spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn...
Hop.
Hier haben wir noch eins hoch.
Oh.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der kam da von unten.
Scheint nicht.
Aber hier haben wir auf jeden Fall einen guten Blick Richtung B.
Da sollte jetzt keiner durchkommen, hoffe ich mal.
Alter!
N8!
Ich glaube, da ist einer durch.
Fuck.
N8, Pepega.
Ach, shit. Okay.
Das kam jetzt echt von allen Seiten.
Hey, guys, how to change Firemon?
Lull, alt F4.
Die Leute.
Das Spiel ist uralt, ne?
Also, entweder war das Troll.
Was ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann.
So alt für das Game ist.
Die Musik im Hintergrund immer noch.
So, also ich habe Terran Highway gevotet.
Mal gucken, was jetzt kommt.
Ich hoffe, es kommt mal wieder Terran Highway.
Das ist einer der underratedsten Rush-Maps
überhaupt.
Richte Pepega-Runde, ja.
Aber der Chat ist...
Aber hier.
Der Chat ist auf Platz 1 und der Chat ist auf Platz 2.
Ich bin auf Platz 3.
Also die Chat-Stellvertreter quasi.
Ups.
Ähm.
Hat jemand von euch dieses neue Ubisoft Battle Royale mal gespielt?
Ah, Terran Highway.
Beste.
Hat jemand dieses Ubisoft Battle Royale mal gespielt?
Ich habe nur 10 Minuten im Stream geguckt.
Ich fand, es sah ganz okay aus.
Vor allem, weil es...
Weil es ein Spiel ist, was irgendwie ein bisschen auf Geschwindigkeit geht.
Wie heißt es?
Hyper...
Hyperspace?
Ne, äh.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Ach, das ist Dreier Squad Only.
Na gut, das hat man ja bei Apex gesehen, dass Dreier Squad Only prinzipiell ganz gut fun...
Hyperscape, genau.
Dass das prinzipiell ganz gut funktionieren kann.
Äh.
What the fuck ist hier los?
Okay, da wird ein Panzer.
Gut.
Hier gehe ich mit dem Panzer.
Ich bin zwar kein Engie, aber gebe hier den Panzer.
BB-Gas.
Das sind keine PP-Gas, das sind BB-Gas.
Wo, warte mal, wo war...
Ich habe ewig keinen Terran Highway.
Wo waren hier die Abwehrkanonen?
Hier, genau.
Excellent.
Oh, ich dachte, die da irgendwo...
Mach das Haus kaputt.
Ah.
Monka.
Ich kann den Panzer nicht reparieren.
Ich habe nichts dabei.
Äh.
Ich verpiss mich mal kurz.
Wir machen jetzt hier.
Huge.
Huge Flank.
Nee, nee, wir machen keinen Huge Flank.
Wir machen jetzt hier Huge, Huge Flank.
Und bashen den Gegner.
Nein, nein, wir bashen den Gegner nicht.
Ist gut, ist gut, ist gut.
Regt euch ab.
Ich bashe den Gegner doch.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut, Mann.
Meine Güte.
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
Die, die, die ballern einmal drei Kilometer nach.
Lull.
Okay, wir sind anscheinend da schon richtig, richtig am Start.
Äh, hallo?
Jeep.
Okay, da, wir, das kann durchaus sein, dass wir jetzt gebasht werden.
Und da drinnen war ein Gegner.
Ich habe es gesehen.
Battlefield.
Okay, man darf hier nicht durch.
Alles klar.
Ah, ah, ah.
Lässt du mich in Ruhe?
BB Gas.
Stream Snipe.
Ah, Gott.
Jetzt kannst du da durch.
Ja, jetzt schon.
Jetzt steht aber der Panzer davor.
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
Okay.
Wir spawnen mal eine Runde als Panzer.
Mann.
Äh.
Ne, oder du willst jetzt hier nicht stehen bleiben?
What the fuck?
Linksrum.
Da, wo viele Leute sind.
Wir fahren jetzt zu Corona Iran und dann werden die geowned.
Ich hoffe, hier sind keine Minen drin.
Wir treffen nichts.
Oh, Mann.
Nein.
Warum, warum bin ich jetzt, jetzt verreckt, ey?
Mann, genau an dem Moment, wo ich ausgestiegen bin, schießt er da drauf.
Was soll das, ey?
Sucked.
Huge Suck.
Okay, unser, unser Pantsman rückt an.
Okay.
Rechts.
Zack.
Next.
Gift Gegner.
Ich kann retten, ich kann retten.
Passt schon, passt schon.
Ich rette.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hinter, hinter muss man.
Alles klar.
Excellent.
Zack.
Weiter geht's.
Komm, wir müssen jetzt, mach den Panzer weg.
Ja, genau, gut, gut, gut, gut, sehr gut.
Der ist, der ist im Gebüsch irgendwo drin, der Dude.
Ah, Monka S.
Wie lang die Prime Werbung ist.
Äh, ich weiß nicht, wie lang ist denn die Prime Werbung?
Wie lang ist so die Prime Werbung?
Okay, okay, okay.
Excellent.
Hier ist irgendein Dude drinne.
Äh, okay.
Irgendwo hier ist ein Dude drinne.
Irgendwo hier ist er drinne.
Ha.
Okay, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo er lang kommt.
Nein.
Oh Gott, ey, was sind denn die Gegner?
Die checken ja alles sofort.
Das sind richtig Schnellchecker, die Gegner.
Aha.
Wir müssen die Treppe hoch, wir müssen die Treppe hoch.
By the way, diese Waffe suckt Balls.
Diese Waffe suckt so hardcore.
Die ist so schlecht.
Da machst du nichts kaputt mit.
Machst du nichts kaputt mit.
Ey, ich muss was anderes, ich muss was anderes reinmachen.
Kannst du UMP?
Ja, ja, kann ich, kann ich.
Äh.
Irgendwo.
Komm, M, M.
M. M4.
Bad Company 3?
Oh ja, Bad Company 3 wäre massive.
M4, beste.
Äh, Change Item?
Warte mal, was ist das zweite? Ah, UMP.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die so gut war in dem Game.
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie hat man noch mal die Waffen customised?
So, ne.
Loadout.
Accessories.
Ich habe hier nichts für die UMP, okay.
Egal, excellent.
Okay, fahren wir mal unsere ewig lang...
Woah!
Was ist mit euch los hier?
Okay.
Die haben keinen Bock. Die wollen nicht.
Die wollen da nicht ranfahren.
Die denken sich, nee, pepega.
Bebega, keinen Bock.
Panzer.
Massive S'more.
Woah!
Der kommt hier rum jetzt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir so viele gekillt. Let's go.
Kommt ran, Leute. Kommt ran.
Ich kann hier doch nicht alleine vor. Wie soll ich das denn machen?
Okay, da kommt wenigstens ein Auto.
Ey, das kannst du voll knicken.
Ha, der kommt nicht raus.
Guckt es euch mal an.
Er kommt nicht raus.
Wo ist eigentlich Monka...
Wo ist Monka Corona hin?
Do something, Team.
Mach!
Also es ist definitiv wenig...
Es ist wenig Druck nach vorne da, ja?
Brauchst du die Elite?
Ich brauch ein paar gute Leute.
Wo ist denn links hin?
Wo ist denn Corona...
Corona Iran hin?
Kannst du voll knicken hier gerade.
Ja, ja, alles klar.
Alles klar, Battlefield, okay.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Alles, alles klar.
Okay.
Lull.
Was auch immer das jetzt gerade gewesen ist.
Oh, ich hoffe, ich komme noch irgendwie durch.
Man muss das übrigens...
Also wenn man es gescheit macht, synchronisiert man das halbwegs.
Also man fährt nicht mit dem M-Track vor, um dann mit dem M-Track zu...
What the fuck?
Um dann mit dem M-Track zu sterben und dann fährt man nicht mit dem Panzer vor, um mit dem Panzer zu sterben.
Du fährst nach Möglichkeit mit den ganzen Sachen vor, wenn du Fahrzeug-Action machst.
Max, beschäftig dich mit Apple.
Ja, das wird...
Sauschnell.
Also für Armverhältnisse.
Also das, was im iPad drin ist und das, was im Smart...
iPhone drin ist...
Oh, nice Kill!
Ist ja schon saumäßig schnell.
Und das, denke ich, kann durchaus auch im Desktop Konkurrenz machen.
Da kommt man nicht durch.
Okay, das war zu viel
Dauerfeuer-Abenteuer
Ja, ich hab letztens gelesen, die sind besser
Ich hab letztens gelesen, wir wechseln mal
den Server, ich hab letztens gelesen
die sind besser und schneller
als
die Samsung-Dinger
Also mit 4-Kern und
Emulation sind die schneller als die
8-Kern-Samsung-Dinger
Scheint nicht übel zu sein
Was hat man hier sonst noch zu bieten?
Ähm, Demovent-Peak
Eine Runde Demovent-Peak können wir uns tatsächlich mal geben
Eine Runde Demovent-Peak können wir uns
Es gibt halt gerade nicht so
wirklich viele Server, ne?
Der hier ist wohl noch ganz gut, der hat sogar DLCs
drauf, aber ich mein Ping von 140
Ähm
Der Rest ist ja nix da, es ist entweder
Es ist entweder Rush Classics
64 Slot, Demovent-Peak
64 Slot, 48
Die wissen glaube ich nicht so genau, was Sache ist
Was geht denn hier ab?
Battlefield 3 geht
Oh guck mal, wir haben Squad-Cover
Dann brauchen wir Squad
Suppression
Nein, bleib mal
Oh, das geht ja schon gut los
Das geht ja schon gut los
What the fuck
BB-Gas wieder
What the hell?
Ne, ist nicht 64 Spieler, steht 48 dran
Die wissen selber nicht so genau
Es steht 64 Spieler
drin
Aber
Es ist irgendwie nur
48 Spieler
Was auch immer
Ist Adaptive
Eigentlich richtig coole Sache, ja
Man könnte sowas ja auch
in Battlefield 5 machen, wenn es ordentliche
Server geben würde, aber es gibt keine ordentlichen Server
Warte mal, ich lauf übelst PP-Gar gerade
Der beste Weg hier am Anfang ist
Bevor die hier ihre
Runterspring-Action machen, auf die linke Seite zu gehen
I'm no cheater
No cheater
Leute, habt ihr das gelesen?
Gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen Cheater, der sagt, er ist Cheater?
Okay
Excellent
Ist der jetzt gestorben, der Dude?
Die Grafik ist
Und das sind nur Medium-Settings oder so, ne?
Okay
Der Heli macht mich nervös
Oh fuck, ich hab kaum noch Muni
Der Heli macht mich nervös da oben
Der Heli macht mich nervös
Nein
Heli, du siehst mich nicht
Und jetzt Winkel
Ja, ah, ah, excellent
Jetzt
Okay
Okay, die Gegner haben keinen Bock
Hier neben abzuspringen
Da haben die keinen Bock drauf
Hier
Von wo? Von wo?
Ich hasse Gegner die so
Gestelzt spielen
So irgendwie
Du siehst sie nicht und auf einmal liegt das M-Com
Hier ist einer abgesprungen
Den holen wir mal schnell, hier unseren Dude.
Ich wollte ihm eigentlich erst noch die Waffe klauen.
Wow, wow, wow, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ach Gott, ich, das...
Wow, oh, oh, oh, nein, Heli, Heli, Heli.
Nein, nein, Heli, Heli, geh weg.
Wonka, Heli.
Kriegen wir das noch?
Okay, ich brauch seine Waffe.
Gib mir deine Waffe.
Hallo?
Okay.
Äh, okay, das ist...
Warum hat er an dieser Base...
Warum hat er an dieser Base das Panzerabwehr-Ding?
Moment, was?
Wie hat mich der Heli denn da drin gestelzt gerade?
Ah, wir Counter-Heli-stelzen, okay.
Okay, die sind auf dem Dach.
Dann gehen wir auch mal aufs Dach.
Alter, Elite-Soldat, kletter mal schneller.
Weißt du, es ist Elite-Soldat und braucht drei Stunden, so eine Leiter hochzukrabbeln.
Get rekt!
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Ich mach doch alles schon weg.
Nein, nein, nein, spring runter.
Okay.
Hier kommt jetzt, kommt jetzt links einer, klar.
Oh, ne, links ist schon einer durch.
Jetzt links.
Fast, fast.
Meine Güte, so viele Gegner.
Epic-Pro-Gamer-Stream, so hardcore.
Wenn man Pro so definiert, dass ich Geld verdiene...
Ähm...
Dann hab ich sogar einen Sub gekriegt.
Ja, ja, Pro-Gamer-Stream, excellent.
Huge, massive Battlefield 3 Pro.
Returning to game, excellent.
Oh, oh, die sind oben.
Die machen, die machen Dachstelz.
Die machen entsetzliche Dachstelzer.
Aber die können von da an ja nix legen.
Oh.
Ich bin paranoid, äh.
Weil hier permanent was ist.
Ich bin hardcore paranoid, was ist hier los?
Oh, der legt jetzt, der macht Legehände.
Oder von hinten?
Ey, ich weiß gar nicht...
Wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo?
Okay, ich aim das jetzt hier ab, bis da was runtergeübt kommt.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt was.
Ich hab, ich hab einen Fallschirm gehört, ich hab einen Fallschirm gehört.
Excellent.
Okay, gehen wir mal hier außen rum.
Was? Hinter mir!
Alter, am Arsch der Welt steht er.
Und jetzt haben sie gelegt. Kaum bin ich da weg, haben sie gelegt.
Und die Typen fliegen lieber am Arsch der Welt mit dem Heli rum, äh.
Okay, nächste Base.
Nächste Base.
Also richtig gemacht.
Richtig gemacht kann man nächste Base nicht einnehmen.
Unmöglich.
Oh, lulululul.
Nein, nein, Heli, Heli, gehst du weg?
Heli, Mann.
Ah, fuck, an der Seite noch einer.
So, ähm.
Also das, die nächste Base ist,
wirklich schwer.
Es sei denn, die sind richtig Big Brain und machen Heli von hinten durch den Tunnelstelz.
Aber ansonsten ist die Base wirklich sehr, sehr schwierig.
Allerdings muss man auf die andere Seite.
Andere Seite und die OP-Posi einnehmen.
Die OP-Posi ist hier.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, okay.
By the way, ist euch mal aufgefallen, ich wurde nicht einmal gerätzt die Runde im Vergleich zum, zum, zum letzten Mal.
Also als wir das gute Team am Start hatten, wo wir da durchgegangen sind durch Medien,
hast du gleich gemerkt, laufend, laufend Dauereds, beeindruckende Posi, ich weiß.
Aber das ist die beste, die beste Posi im Tunnel.
By the way, das Team suckt, wir wechseln das Team mal, weil ich gebe mal ein Echo, da kann da Wolle mit.
Die Sache ist die, ähm, wir brauchen ja Squad Cover.
Was bringt's mir?
Hä?
Moment, wo, wo sind wir überhaupt?
Moment, wo, wo sind wir?
Ach, wir sind hier.
Wir sind voll krass, äh, Flank, äh, Flank, Rino, äh, was?
Das gibt's doch nicht, dass die mich jetzt da gespottet haben schon.
Hallo, sterben, please.
Ha, ha.
Oh, lo, lo, lo, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ah.
Okay, der Flanks sagt.
Der Flanks, das ist der, das ist der Müller.
Pff.
Wir müssen hier innen drin.
Wenn er das halten und gut ist.
Linke Seite ist erstmal wichtig.
Rechts ist schwer durchzukommen.
Wobei es fast alle, es sind, es sind fast alle links.
Dann gehe ich mal rechts.
Weil ich, ich hab schon so im Gefühl gleich gemacht.
Bui, bui, bui.
Ah, nee, rechts sitzt es halt.
Okay, nee, nee, rechts sitzen sie auch noch.
Alles klar.
What the?
Das ist ein...
Haben die unseren Panzer?
Haben die unseren Panzer geklaut?
Ist das unser Panzer?
Können die sich mal...
Die sind ja die ganze Zeit nur am rumkacken, wer hier am cheaten ist.
Und wir haben kein, keinerlei Spawn drin oder so.
Was ist hier los?
Woher sind das wieder...
Naja.
Diffused.
Ist das jetzt unser Panzer?
Ja.
Moment, was?
Okay.
Links sitzt einer.
Ich, ich, ich diffuse mal mit.
Dass wir es auf jeden Fall durchkriegen.
Oh, was jetzt?
Mon, Monka, äh, lag.
Huge lag.
Okay.
Da renne ich jetzt definitiv nicht rüber.
Da renne ich jetzt definitiv nicht rüber zum Diffusen.
Kannst du knicken.
Also irgendwie ist das gerade massiv bebeger alles.
Mal gucken.
Vielleicht nächste Runde, wenn wir von Anfang an dabei sind, dann geht irgendwas.
Spawn.
Da steht der immer noch am Arsch der Welt rum.
Alter, was?
Oh Gott, ey.
Wo bin ich denn hier gelandet?
The fuck?
Was ist das hier?
Oh.
Wir spawnen so weit weg, dass wir nicht mehr diffusen.
Ach, boah.
Das ist so krass fail.
Moment, was?
Ah, das war ein anderer.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Also wenn das der gleiche war, da wüsste ich auch nicht.
Das ist so fail da hinten am Arsch der Welt.
WTF?
Jetzt haben wir zwei Spawn-Beacons da hinten.
Und wir haben den Tank verloren.
Boah.
Da kriegst du ja an.
Nee, nee, ich fahre keinen Panzer.
Oh, bei noch.
Problem ist, ich habe nichts zum rappen.
Okay.
Zack.
Stell sind wir da mit dem Scope rum.
Disabled.
Okay, keine Ahnung, wo er hin ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was uns da genau anleuchtet gerade.
Sag mal, was ist eigentlich gerade mit meiner Grafik los?
Der Tunnel verschwindet.
Der Tunnel verschwindet permanent.
Okay, wir müssen ihn definitiv weg.
Okay, next.
Okay, das war zu hoch.
Wo ist der Panzer?
Bam.
Oh, oh.
Ich habe Angst.
Panzer.
Reload.
Zack.
Da geht er down.
The Pants Man.
Was zum...
Geil, er hat mich da gerade getroffen.
Was hat mich da gerade gehittet?
Muss der Panzer hin?
Die Panzer fahren übrigens anstrengend in dem Game.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo der Panzer hin ist.
Sollen wir mal hinterfahren?
Näh.
Okay.
Block.
Ja.
Auf.
Bam.
Oh, was?
Kommst du hier rum?
Oh, rappen, please.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht genau, von wo die uns gerade...
Ah, die haben über den Berscht geschossen, hä?
Aber der Heli ist auch down.
Nice.
Okay, zumindest hatten die Schwierigkeiten, jetzt durch den Tunnel zu kommen, seit wir da gepants mannt haben.
Wow.
What?
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Ah.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung, von wo das ist, ey.
Heli Javelin, ja.
Aber wir können das sogar diffusen jetzt.
Wir können das diffusen.
Weil der Up-Aim-Typ am M-Com ist...
Oh, nice.
Ah, nee, wir haben es nicht erwischt.
Aber wo war denn das andere M-Com?
Da vorne.
Oh, fuck.
Hier ist ja richtig was los.
Wow.
Manga.
Es.
Huh.
Alter.
Alter, ich...
Was ist hier los?
Das ist ja nicht normal.
Das ist ja gerade nicht normal.
Nein, das ist kein Fenster.
Sieht nur so aus.
Pff.
Oh, das war ein Revive.
Geil, ein Revive.
Alle links neben euch ist der, Alter.
Ja.
Poggers Revive.
Oh, dankeschön.
Excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent.
Jetzt haben wir euch am Sack, Leute.
Oh, nee.
Jetzt haben wir euch am Sack.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Panzer.
Direkt vor meiner Nase.
So, wenn die rausspringen, dann machen wir euch platt.
Einer war hier, glaube ich, noch.
Einer lebt noch.
Oder einer, sagen wir mal, einer lebte noch.
Oder lebt immer noch?
Nee, jetzt ist er down.
Wow.
Da war noch einer.
Haben wir den?
Der Heliman?
Da muss...
Da ist man immer voll paranoid, dass da einer abspringt.
Heliman?
Wisst ihr?
So, da bist du permanent paranoid, dass da einer abspringt.
Haha.
Okay, Pog.
Ah, ist meiner.
Okay.
Ah, an B, an B, an B, an B.
Excellent.
Wie heißt der?
Oh, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Irgendwas mit 48 Mann.
64 Mann, 64 Mann.
Ja, so, die mag ich.
Die mag ich.
Ja, die mag ich.
Alpons, Panzer, Panzers.
Oh, was ist hier links los?
Oh, da kann man nicht drüber hüpfen.
Na toll.
Äh.
Ich habe über mir was gehört.
Ich habe über mir einen Fallschirm gehört.
Zum Glück ist es nicht Bad Company 2, weil in Bad Company 2 könnten die jetzt einfach
das Haus kaputt machen und gut war es.
Ich muss mal die Dudes da hinten bashen.
Pff.
Haha, der Schneiber, Mann.
Ist da oben noch ein Schneibermann?
Nee, der Schneibermann ist weg.
Jetzt fliegen sie wieder rein und springen ab.
Die springen ab.
Sind die jetzt tot oder sind die rausgesprungen?
Nice, nice, nice.
Wir haben den Heli von ihnen.
Excellent.
Hoffentlich ist das ein Dude, der fliegen kann.
Hallo.
Hoffentlich ist das einer, der fliegen kann.
Ich kann nicht retzen.
Ich wollte retzen, aber vergiss es.
Es wäre schlecht gewesen, hätte ich gerettet.
Oh, nein.
Weggesprengt.
Oder auch nicht.
Jetzt pushen sie ganz gut rein.
Wir haben, glaube ich, keinen vorne mehr.
Unser Panzertyp ist jetzt nicht...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, eben ist hier der Worty oder so gefahren.
Der hat die gut in Schach gehalten.
Jetzt ist unser anderer Panzerman am Start.
Diffuse, diffuse.
Nein, fuck.
Okay, das war es.
Das war es.
Hallo?
Nope.
Ripp.
Aber wir haben doch noch gut reingehauen am Schluss.
Letzte Base war es hier.
Letzte Base.
Wir sind quasi gejoint.
Irgendwann, als es gerade zum Tunnel gekommen ist.
Und dann...
Das ging doch noch.
Gar nicht mehr so übel.
Okay, eine Runde kann ich noch machen.
Dann gibt es wieder Essen.
Zinkstorm.
Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Big Brain Subscription.
Stop.
Unterstützt Battlefield 3 eigentlich Borderless?
Borderless Window?
Dass ich Emotes drüber machen kann?
Leider darf man ja in den über eine Minute Zeit, die man jetzt hier hat, keine Settings einstellen in dem Spiel.
Da hat Steiß nämlich gedacht, nee, nee, das ist eine schlechte Idee, wenn wir den Leuten irgendwas zu tun geben inzwischen in den Runden.
Ja, du kannst doch nicht mal chatten.
Du kannst doch nicht mal Trash-Talken im Chat.
Du kannst nichts während der Runde machen.
Nicht mal Trash-Talken.
Das ist doch schon hart.
Zu wilde Emotes.
Battle-Log auch gute Idee.
Ich muss euch mal sagen, im Nachhinein betrachtet...
Ich weiß, dass sie in Battlefield 4 haben sie das Ganze wieder zusätzlich reingepatcht und so.
Aber im Nachhinein betrachtet, ich finde, so schlecht war das mit dem Battle-Log gar nicht mal.
Ich hab's auch übelst gehatet am Anfang, ja.
Aber wozu sollte man das eigentlich machen im Game?
Ich mein, so ein Browser ist in sowas doch eigentlich viel besser.
Nein, nicht Smoken, da seh ich doch nix.
Nicht Smoken.
Das Smoken war keine allzu gute Idee, Kollege.
Letztendlich hat's...
Da oben noch einer.
Okay, das hatten wir schnell jetzt.
Das hatten wir jetzt echt schnell.
Der Automan.
Wenn wir jetzt den Heli noch irgendwie runterkriegen, das wär richtig Pro, weil dann können wir frei pushen, wie wir wollen.
Müsste eigentlich reichen, von der Zeit her.
Drei, zwei, oh.
Boah, Monka-S.
Monkas, Monkas.
Aber richtiger Monkas.
Oh, Mann.
N8, weg N8.
Am wenigsten ist er down.
Ich hab da immer so einen halben Millimeter daneben, oder einen halben Zentimeter daneben geschossen.
Wir sind ja...
Was geht?
Was gibt das hier, wenn's fertig ist?
Das ist ja Speed Rush.
Wolle, ich guck aus dem Fenster.
Ah, nee, ich hol dich.
Ich versuch hier raus zu...
Ich komm nicht aus dem Haus.
Nee, ich spawn lieber bei mir.
Spawn lieber bei mir.
Okay, das war eine schlechte Idee.
Das war eine schlechte Idee, aufs Dach zu gehen.
Ach, der war unter mir.
Wie ist der Dude denn da hingekommen?
Nee, das bin ich.
Das bin ich, oder?
Nee, das kann ich nicht sein mit dem RPG.
Okay, Game, dann blick ich nicht mehr durch gerade.
Das war der G...
Wo kam der denn bitte schön her?
Der war da angeblich irgendwo im Haus schon.
What?
Okay, jetzt blick ich nicht mehr durch.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht diffusen.
Diffusen sucked.
Nein, nicht diffusen.
Wo sind die?
Ah, shit, jetzt einen durchgepusht.
Hätte klappen können, hätte klappen können.
Aber wir sind ultra geil da reingekommen mit dem Auto.
Das war hier...
What a big brain play.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hinten war auch noch einer.
Monka, Giga.
Irgendwo hier ist er, ich seh ihn.
Ich hab ihn doch gerade gesehen.
So, jetzt hier.
Nächster Push.
Das Spiel möchte nicht, dass ich hier drauf komme.
Oh, denied.
Oh, oh.
Das war knapp, Leute, das war knapp.
Ich glaube, ich mach manchmal den Fehler, dass ich als Defender das mache, was ich als Attacker machen würde.
Was Fail ist, weil das die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Äh, äh.
Big brain, oh.
Äh.
Stuck.
Kann man irgendwie durch?
Sag mal, warum haben wir das schon geahmt?
Ich hab hier den...
Den Ultra-Big-Brain-Anflug gemacht und wir haben schon gelegt.
WTF?
Da machst du hier den...
Die Pilot...
Pilot-Skills, äh...
Auf an 1.000 und dann bringt's doch nicht mal was.
Was ist das?
Und jetzt sitzt einer hinten in der Ecke und ich hab's nicht geguckt.
Das, aber ihr müsst, ihr müsst zugeben, ne?
Schöner, schöner Anflug war das.
Das war ein echt nicer Anflug.
So.
Richtig pro um die Ecke und das hat keiner mitgekriegt.
Kommt bestimmt gleich was von hinten.
Oder auch nicht?
Okay.
Wollt grad sagen.
Alter, könnt ihr jetzt mal aufhören zu überleben, please?
Okay.
Alles weg.
Na.
Puh.
Ha.
Der, der wollte mich jetzt killen und ist gecrashed mit dem Heli.
Oder auch nicht.
Es hat sich so angehört, als wäre der gecrashed, ne?
Also die Runde ist wirklich Big-Brain-Team angesagt.
Das ist, das ist wieder hier Zerstörung, Zerstörungs-Pushen hier, die, die, die machen ja gar nix.
Einfach mal ne Runde T-Banken, weil's geht.
Okay, links, rechts.
Wir gehen mal links durch.
Rechts finde ich persönlich eigentlich, ne, wir machen, wir machen Big-Brain-Team.
Oh, oh, Panzer.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Panzer, nicht, nicht auf mich schießen.
Nicht auf mich schießen.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Ah, excellent.
Ich muss die Runde beenden.
Ich muss überhaupt nix machen, das ist richtig nice.
Wir gewinnen einfach so.
Nein.
Wir gewinnen gerade einfach so.
Easy as fuck.
Hier war ich noch nie drauf.
Ich, ich, ich war, oh, legit, legit, ich war hier, oh, fuck.
Ich war noch nie drauf, seitdem ich, seitdem ich das Spiel spiele, noch nie.
Aber es ist auch so ein scheiß Spot, vor allem als Attacker.
Da bist du ja exposed ohne Ende.
Streamst du regelmäßig, Max?
Ja, fast jeden Tag in letzter Zeit.
Also, sorry, Leute.
Die Runde kann ich nicht carryen, weil wir die Gegner heftig, heftig zerstören.
Uncarryable.
Diesmal wäre ich gecarried.
Okay, okay, wenigstens ein paar Rättspunkte.
Gebt mir ein paar Rättspunkte.
Rättspunkte.
Lass mich rättsen.
Nein.
Wenigstens ein paar Punkte fürs Rättsen, ha?
Okay, jetzt, was ist hier los?
Auf hier.
YOLO-Rätts.
Nein, der Typ steht drauf.
No.
Also, die Runde ist wirklich easy as fuck.
Muss gar nix machen.
Du wirst gerätst und, und, die M-Cops sind nach 5 Sekunden drauf.
Easy as fuck.
Moment, Leute.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
So, das musste mal gesagt werden.
Das musste mal gesagt werden.
Oh.
Ich glaube, direkt vor uns steht hier einer.
Oh, fuck.
Shit.
Das war zu viel.
Aber richtig krass.
Die sind voll gut.
Mein Team ist übelst gut.
Ich muss überhaupt nix machen.
Das ist nice.
Ich kann einfach ein bisschen rumpelpegern.
Ohne, dass wir was machen.
Was passiert?
Weißt du?
Einfach eine Runde rumpelpegern und wir gewinnen trotzdem.
We're tough.
Easy.
Oh, oh, oh.
Vor uns ist ein Panzer.
Wir müssen weg.
Pa.
Ah.
Ah, ah, ah.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ich raff gar nix in dem Game.
Das ist halt auch, äh, recht...
Actionreich, ne?
Also, da ist, da ist recht viel los.
Vor allem, was es in dem Game übelst wirrend macht, ist diese Suppression.
Dieser Suppression-Effekt.
Wo du nix siehst.
Easy win.
Die i...
Das war die easieste Runde of my life, ey.
Ich hab noch nie so eine einfache Runde gespielt.
Ja, das war easy.
Du musstest überhaupt nix machen.
Einfach nur geradeaus laufen.
Da waut's hier aus dem Chat.
Da ist er, hab ich gesehen.
Ich, ich...
Habt sich im Auge.
12-0.
Easy win.
Okay, 12.08.50.
Es gibt Essen.
Ich müsste jetzt eigentlich off.
Was?
Gucken, was für eine Map kommt.
Oder sind wir noch auf dem Dammer-Wend...
Ich glaub, wir sind auf dem Dammer-Wend-Peak-Only-Server.
Na, was, was für eine Map wird da wohl kommen?
Ich raten.
Dammer-Wend-Peak.
Ähm.
Eine geht...
Och.
Dammer-Wend-Peak-Defense, wenn man, wenn, wenn das Team OP ist, ist schwierig.
Weil, da passiert nix.
Oh.
Oh, Team-Balance.
Nochmal Attacker.
Okay, ich glaub, jetzt wird's schwieriger.
Ich glaub, jetzt wird's...
Jetzt wird's schwieriger.
Okay, wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal, wie gut's...
Wir gucken mal, wie gut wir bei der ersten Base durchkommen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich muss futtern.
Ich geh wahrscheinlich gleich auf nach der ersten Base.
Oder mal gucken, wie gut wir durchkommen.
Äh.
What?
Battlefield-Logik.
Vor allem, da war das halbe Magazin drinne.
Ja, da machst du nix.
So, gehen wir mal in den Squad, wo was los ist.
Drinne.
Oh, guck mal, wir haben ein Auto.
Nee, in das Auto kommen wir dann mal rein.
Okay, nee, das ist so ne Dammer-Wend-Peak-Spawn-Camp-Runde.
Na, über was ist es jetzt rüber?
Okay, Leute.
Das ist so ne Dammer-Wend-Peak-Spawn-Camp-Runde.
Wahrscheinlich geh ich doch was essen jetzt.
Game Team 1.
Alles klar.
Jetzt erst mal Afk.
Erst mal Afk einrubbeln.
Was?
Move for Balance?
For fucking Balance?
Wir kriegen auf den Sack.
Warum werden die guten Spiele aus Balance-Gründen gemovet?
Leck mich, ey.
Ich glaub, es geht los.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern, Leute.
Wir sehen uns später.
Oder so.
Mal gucken.
Bis dann.
See you.